the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in A
Song of Ice and Fire video this will be
a short update video about something
that happened in the Game of Thrones
season 8 finale as you all know we saw
brain stark become the new king of
Westeros during the season 8 finale that
decision left many fans in disbelief
mostly because it did not seem like
something that whatever happened not
only because it felt like it came out
absolutely nowhere but also because we
have heard this character say many times
I do not want anything but at the end of
the season he goes down to King's
Landing for this very reason he
literally says why do you think I came
all this way this has led to many of us
wondering will this also happen in the
books well it looks like we now have
that answer when Isaac Hempstead Wright
sat down with HBO to discuss the making
a game of Thrones he revealed the answer
during that interview the actor goes on
to say creators David Benioff and Dan
Weiss told me there were two things
author george RR martin had planned for
bran and that was the Hodor revelation
and that he would be king so that's
pretty special to be directly involved
in something that is a part of George's
vision it was a really nice way to wrap
it up so now it does seem as if this
will happen in the books as well ever
since this article came out I have
already started to see some fans on
social media have a negative reaction to
it one fan said well I guess I don't
need to read the books anymore the
show's ending sucked and so will the
books brain Stark is a useless character
I did want to say something in response
to that I would try not to compare
brains character in the show to brains
character in the books sure they might
have the same ending but that doesn't
mean it will suck because the show
decided to do it the way that they did
you have to realize Georgia or Martin
will not rush to his ending the same way
the show did brain Stark's character
will be far more fascinating in the
books in fact it already is since the
very first chapter
Song of Ice and Fire is a brain stark
chapter then we might see it as the
final chapter as well as of right now
brain is still inside of the cave with
Bloodraven in the children of the forest
the night King hasn't even been
introduced as of yet and he may never
become a character but I do think we
will find out someone or something is
leading all the white walkers in the
whites
whenever the white walkers do begin to
invade Westeros in the books bran stark
will be instrumental in that battle it
will not go down like it did in the show
there is no way George R Martin has
brain on this journey to become the next
three-eyed crow to only sit by the
weirwood tree and fly a bunch of ravens
you have to remember brain is made aware
of this threat almost immediately right
after Jaime throws brand out of the
window bran Stark goes into a coma just
like he did in the show however
something happens to him in the books
that we did not see in the show this is
when bran is shown exactly why he is
needed in fact the crow tells him this
is why you must live as brain is in his
coma the three-eyed crow takes brain on
a journey where he gets to see many
different things he sees his mom his dad
and even Jon Snow when he's at the wall
but it's the very last thing brain has
shown that indicates why he is needed
right after brain has shown Jon sleeping
at the wall they then began to fly far
beyond the wall into the heart of winter
as he is showing this to brand he starts
to get very afraid in fact he even cries
out when brain looks down all he can see
is snow and cold and death he can see
the bones of a thousand other dreamers
he was desperately afraid I think you
can all take a guess at why brain is so
afraid we know what's out there in those
woods and we know why brain is
surrounded by death in that moment this
is when the crow says the brand now you
know now you know why you must live
because winter is coming like I said
there is no way that George is writing
this and one of brand's first chapters
so he can only sit by a weirwood tree
during the battle against the white
walkers you see the Game of Thrones show
runners David and Dan could have given
us a much better ending if they would
have only taken their time
HBO wanted Game of Thrones to be on
television for a decade George even said
that he wanted them to go
for 13 seasons but as soon as they
realize George did not have the winds of
winter ready for them they decided to
get out as soon as they could they only
wanted to adapt his story not tell their
own this led to them racing to a
conclusion because they decided to do it
that way this show suffered things were
now happening at breakneck speed but
this will not be the way that George
tells his story why do you think it's
taken him so long to make the next book
I actually think the winds of winter
could be as best won once it's actually
finished so we may see brains start to
become the next king in the books as
well but I think it will feel a lot more
natural since George is taking his time
telling his story his way there will be
logical explanations for why things are
happening I would encourage everyone to
go and read them as soon as you can if
you haven't already if the show left you
feeling unsatisfied I would read the
book so you can be ready for the winds
of winter in about a year also if you
are interested about everything brain is
shown during his coma dream I will leave
a link down below I think it's a
fascinating chapter and I made a video
all about it I believe in the video I do
read the entire chapter then I break it
down by giving my interpretations of
what he sees I happen to think it has
big implications for the end game check
it out if you haven't already anyways I
just wanted to check in with everyone
and give you that update about what the
actor said during the interview let me
know your thoughts on all of this as
always thanks for watching another video
and thank you to everyone who supports
the channel I hope you all have a great
day I'll see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]